hey guys welcome back to what's in my
bag how to Hollywood edition I have Joe
Baker here with me we just did this Lily
Reinhardt look and I have been watching
things with her we've been looking
through her makeup she's been doing my
makeup and we part just playing just
playing and I want to know what are some
of your favorite things that you have in
your kit right now these are my five
favorite products right now and two of
them is like new to me this week I'm
gonna start off with Mac has made these
amazing eye glosses and this is now my
favorite lightly doped oh my god and
it's got little shimmery particles it's
basically like a unicorn pooped in a jar
it's most delicious stuff and you can
just tap it on any eyeshadow John touch
it oh my gosh it's big yeah I love it
and you can just tap it on the top of
your eyelids and it just instantly
brings this cool modern look to your
makeup next thing is I've recently
become familiar with EOS or iOS or
however you like to say it the new
crystal balms
there's see-through see-through look at
it it looks like magic it looks like
something from the labyrinth yeah so I'm
loving bees and they feel and they you
think this is my own personal
I wouldn't recommend sharing this and it
feels so luxurious when you put it on
its rich but there's also it's only made
up of five oils so a baccardo Isle
coconut or two of the ingredients
there's no beeswax you used and it's
vegan and this is the first of its kind
then I am absolutely obsessed with these
concealers by NIAMS me - oh that's so
good so I've even used these all over
the face in a pinch if I'm really really
busy with a client and we've got like 10
minutes
I've striped this all over the face and
blended it in really quickly and this is
like a good little sneak if you need
like something in your bag but you can
do concealing and also save your skin as
a whole then this first remedy by Hope
Gilman I love all her oils they are
supreme she's an amazing oil blender and
I know feels it so I'm always a bit of
oil yeah client ah it was so good I felt
like I was at the spa today right that's
how it should feel this all should feel
like a lovely delicious experience um so
that they do a travel one and every time
I get on a plane it comes in a
rollerball like a do - I'm just like
well they're all arriving in on my body
and it's like got lemongrass and
uplifting things and bacterial so I love
these oils hope Gilman Yas later that's
right and then this is a new product of
mine - this is a new I've got a new
crush of blush crush and it's Gucci face
in spicy petal and it's the yummiest
looks a bit dirty yeah I know don't care
but it's a really nice soft nudey pink
it's like a perfect buff tone I used it
on you today and it has like microscopic
and sparkly fragments built-ins that you
can barely see but once it goes on the
cheek you get a really soft radiance to
your skin so these new blushes by Gucci
are top of my list thank you so much for
sharing